>>> JUST IN, ALLEN WEISSELBERG,
THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION'S FORMER
CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER WAS
SENTENCED TO FIVE MONTHS IN
JAIL.
NOW, HE PLEADED GUILTY LAST YEAR
TO MULTIPLE TAX CRIMES RELATED
TO FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S REAL
ESTATE EMPIRE.
>> KARA SCANNELL JOYS US NOW.
SURPRISED HE'S GOING TO RIKERS
PRISON WHERE IS WHERE HARD CORE
CRIMINALS GO.
>> ALLEN WEISSELBERG SENTENCED
BY THE JUDGE WHO HAD OVERSEEN
THE TRIAL OF THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION AND SENTENCED HIM
TO A SENTENCE OF FIVE MONTHS IN
JAIL.
IN NEW YORK CITY IF YOU'RE
SENTENCED TO TERM YOU GO TO
RIKERS ISLAND PRISON.
A NOTORIOUS PRISON KNOWN FOR
BEING A DANGEROUS PRISON AND HAS
HAD FEFRL OVERSIGHT FOR SOME
TIME BUT WEISSELBERG BECAUSE OF
THE DEAL HE MADE WHEN HE PLED
GUILTY GOT A SENTENCE OF FIVE
MONTHS IN JAIL AND FIVE YEARS OF
SUPERVISED RELEASE OF THE JUDGE
SAYING TODAY HAVING PRESIDED
OVER THE TRIAL LISTENED TO THE
EVIDENCE AND LISTENED TO THE
TESTIMONY OF WEISSELBERG.
HE SAID IF HE HAD NOT MADE THAT
PROMISE HE WOULD HAVE SENTENCED
HIM TO A MUCH STIFFER SENTENCE.
HE SAID HE WAS -- WHO HE FOUND
SO OFFENSIVE DURING THE TRIAL
WEISSELBERG HAD GOTTEN HIS WIFE
A $6,000 PAYCHECK FROM THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION ENTITIES TO ENABLE
HER TO GET SOCIAL SECURITY
BENEFITS AND THE JUDGE SAID THAT
SINCE WEISSELBERG WAS SO WELL
PAID AND RECEIVED ALL THESE OFF
THE BOOKS COMPENSATION INCLUDING
THE COMPANY PAID APARTMENT, THE
CARS, THE PRIVATE SCHOOL TUITION
FOR HIS SKIDS HE SAID THAT WAS
SO OFFENSIVE HE WOULD HAVE
SENTENCED HIM TO I AGREATER
AMOUNT OF TIME IN JAIL HAD HE
NOT ALREADY MADE THIS DEAL.
NOW, THIS CAME AFTER
WEISSELBERG'S ATTORNEY ASKED FOR
A SOFTER SENTENCE, SAYING THAT
WHEN YOU'RE 75 YEARS OLD, EVERY
MONTH IN JAIL COUNTS, THE JUDGE
OBVIOUSLY REJECTING THAT AND
SAYING THAT HE DID FIND THAT
WEISSELBERG HAD MET ALL THE
TERMS OF HIS PLEA.
HE SENTENCED HIM TO FIVE MONTHS
IN JAIL AND FIVE YEARS OF
SUPERVISED RELEASE.
HE WAS REMANDED